welcome to you heard with perd i'm perd
hapley the story of our guest today is
that they are from the department of
parks and recreation ben wyatt and tom
haverford what up perk big fan
me too perd
what up
the thing about this first question is
i'd like to ask you about the harvest
festival perd it's gonna be amazing
carnival rides games sweden is even
building a plus-size roller coaster for
some of pawnee's obese thrill-seekers
you must be this wide to ride wow that's
gonna be a pretty big roller coaster yep
man did you buy anything for yourself
today yeah i got this pack of socks
plain white socks that's not a treat
donna get me away from him maybe this is
our version of treat yourself day and he
needs to do his version what are you
talking about why if you could blow big
money on one thing
not sock money what would it be
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is a
whole new level of nerd you're right
this is ridiculous what am i doing wait
no no no no no i mean that in a good way
ben listen to me you're part of the
treat yourself team now okay if that
costume somehow makes you happy you're
gonna buy it
and you're gonna wear it out of the
store okay you're gonna treat yourself
yeah you know what i'm gonna do that i'm
gonna
i'm gonna treat myself thanks you
guys thank you
i really needed this
i gotta treat myself
uh oh batman's crying
the internet's not working
ben
we need your help guys i've told you how
to do it you just unplug the router and
then you plug it back in again
i guess i'll do it
still not working well give it a minute
good
okay it's working
good morning ben oh
sorry sorry did i scare you no
i just wanted to remind you of the art
show that's happening tonight at the
community center great well that sounds
cool that sounds like uh something
that'll be a big success you know
i mean like everything that you uh that
you put your your
your paws on your fingers
so i have some ideas for the health
initiative okay how about i swing by
later and we'll just you know go over
everything or we could go out after work
you know go to jj's or something grab a
bite um i don't i don't think i can
but
why don't we just talk about it later in
this building
okay all right but uh you're great and
you have great ideas
and
um
uh
bye
how'd it go
well there were some sticky moments
let's go to the videotape
ah
look who hasn't had gay thoughts who are
you okay yeah i'm fine i'm fine i mean
you know sometimes i feel like i might
need glasses is there a bird in here i
swear i keep seeing a bird in the studio
maybe that's kind of what's happening to
it he was fine until bird started asking
about the boy mayor's stuff what's wrong
with you you look psychotic i was 18
when i was elected mayor okay so excuse
me for that cindy eckert had just turned
me down for senior prom do you know how
that feels i should call her i should i
no i shouldn't and i'm not going to and
i'm proud of myself for that
and then he talked about feeling up
cindy eckert for the first time for
about five minutes
and then the show ended as did our
careers and probably harvest fest
boom
sadness that's the one
if i thought you were serious i'd be
offended bird but i know that we're
buddies i know you wouldn't do that to
me but no this is a birthmark perd okay
this is the little scar i got when i was
nine and i fell off my bike so no i'm
not perfect i can't look away it's um
it's amazing okay wait no here's the
best part okay uh that's all the time we
have here on you heard i'm heard happily
channel four more like turd crapley
[Applause]
i had no right to disparage your town
well i owe you guys an apology too i uh
had a little bad publicity lately and
frankly it's still really easy to score
points by bashing wyatt can't you
just give ben a key to the city here now
in your office where no one will know
your shame
sorry babe no worries i love you
uh you know if people found out i gave
wyatt the key to this idiot i would
never get reelected so
no
what are you doing there wyatt
i'm feeding your eagle
he's starving
it's
it's bronze babe why
the eagle
we should go yeah chief trample nice to
see you hi hey nope
wyatt been a long time hey captain or
captain uh oh captain my captain from
dead poet society
you getting weird already nope i'm good
pawnee's police chief is retiring and
i'm trying to get his endorsement before
he goes i'm really nervous because i
need this for my campaign
and ben is really nervous because he's
afraid of cops i'm not afraid of cops i
have no reason to be i never break any
laws ever
because i'm deathly afraid of cops
look nope i've always liked you but the
new ports run this town and frankly
they've donated a lot of money to the
department mo money mo problems that's
what i always say
how about mo money more protected kevlar
vests that save lives i i sometimes i
say that too i understand you need to
think about it but if you were gonna
make a decision
guys are throwing me a little retirement
thing tonight at o'flynnigan's
there's gonna be beer so i want you to
swing by i'll give you an answer
weirdo can come too all right
let's go oh hey uh may i say the boys in
blue stop our heroes
obviously some more than others
oh boy here comes
9 11. and we're walking okay
go ahead
[Music]
oh
go ahead
oh hey dave go ahead
[Applause]
this place is outstanding
great call leslie knope
look even ben's dancing
well i am very glad you came back up
here
oh
yeah me too yeah so you got a deal
well let me mull everything over and
then
we can reconnect and hash things out
it might get rough but that can be fun
ben can handle it yep i can okay great
it was a pleasure oh mm-hmm
what is wrong with you today did they
cancel game of thrones nothing is wrong
just do your job
and they would never cancel game of
thrones
it's a crossover hit it's not just for
fantasy enthusiasts they're telling
human stories in a fantasy world
fill out the forms please thank you
there's one more thing i want to try
i got you something in london
a traditional barrister's wig oh
wear it for me
yeah
all right
what's up
no not sexy failed experiment take it
off okay just just take it okay no
calculator
oh you like that one huh
we do not get a lot of humor here and
when we do it's wonderful oh ted come in
here
say it to ted when he comes in
so this guy ben wyatt we're looking him
up on alta vista
he's from some hicktown partridge
minnesota and when he's 18
he's elected mayor
[Music]
that's funny that's funny he's 18
becomes the mayor and then blows the
whole budget on an ice skating rink city
goes bankrupt no
you're out of there
what'd you call it again what was it
called
say it
ice town
[Laughter]
i was a kid and when you you
you you end up getting out there and uh
and there's uh
i really wish you guys could see this
guy right now he is dronched in sweat
there's also gonna be ponies at the
harvest festival all right let's take a
caller from douche nation all right talk
to me caller what's up guys just dousing
over here in eagleton sweet seems like
18 is pretty young for a mayor what were
you like 12
the funny um
when
i guess
the fortunate um
can we just
sort of
game over man game over talking about
the highway to
the calzone zone you know
if you want to ask him questions let's
go for it huh let's ask any question
about his past or present just get it
over with ben let's get up here yeah
yeah come on
we'll just ask him a bunch of questions
and then we'll get everything cleared
and out of the way sound good yeah great
good
uh let's take some calls jim
why don't you okay uh caller are you
there
yeah how can you justify raising taxes
for something that'll hurt the town
you